so do you want to be like a uh a dad the
dad and i'll be the son who's like your
stepson but i don't speak english but i
speak spanish but everything i say you
understand and you just answer me like
if i'm groot
yeah i love that you know what i mean
the father and son moving company and
what i want them to do is to move my son
your father and son moving company and i
want him to move my son
it's a father and son moving company or
is it called father's father-son moving
company it's called
no it's a father and son moving we'll
bleep that we have to bleed yeah okay
but it's a father and son moving company
i'm not going to give you the name of it
for the people here and and uh let's see
if they can move my son we'll play along
we'll see what happens here
um and if not then we'll go to the cell
phone we'll see it do you like doing
these kind of things or no no but um
i'm telling you everyone you've had in
so far has not like doing these prank
phone calls no coi did not like it bobby
lee did not like it
so when you leave here today are you
gonna are you gonna tell everybody don't
do the podcast he makes you he makes you
he makes you crank call people yeah
can you hear that yes
this is a moving company right
moving company no
we're a mechanic shop
okay
all righty sir
um
all right
um
i called the wrong i want to do a hello
sir
yeah i'm here yeah we were gonna do a a
prank call on a moving company but i
dialed the wrong number can we do the
prank call on you
um no i'd rather you not no but i have a
fluffy guy who who
do you follow comedy stand up comedy
he's going to play my son in this one
uh unfortunately sorry
we're running a place of business i
can't do that i apologize no no no no
but i really he's very official okay you
got to give him credit
he's he's all about the business gabriel
iglesias is here and i'm howie mandel
and we wanted to do a prank call on you
um yeah howie i i've heard of you i've
heard of gabriel i i respect and
appreciate both of you but
at this point i have uh customers in
line and i have do you want a job you're
somebody's not gonna [ __ ] around i like
this guy oh come on let us do a prank
let us do a prank call on you please
just really quickly
for my podcast
you go for it yeah okay all right okay
okay so you start you start it go ahead
you start it
well we gotta find out how much i get
paid and uh
uh how long i'm gonna be on the phone
for no no this is not this is just for
our personal amusement and the
audience's personal amusement you're not
getting paid for this but this is free
absolutely free but laughter is the best
medicine
i know but we just want to do a joke on
you let us [ __ ] with you for a couple of
minutes
uh and and disturb your time
am i a moving company or am i
i
i called the wrong number
you can be
what would be a funny like what would be
something that you would fall for
and and that i would fall for i i didn't
fall for this so yeah clearly he nothing
and he's not even going for the
no
he's like i know and i really gabriel's
here but i guess i got [ __ ] to do
okay
right you take care of cars what do you
do
we auto repair facility
all right okay so like bondo and paint
jobs and stuff like that oh no engines
transmissions
okay
all right it's getting funnier this is
getting funnier
all right so and if
what would be really annoying to you
like how could we annoy you i think he's
there howie you're doing it you're doing
it
you're you're right on the money and
gabriel not i'm not doing it alone
oh there you go
okay this is a prank call are you busy
right now
yes i am okay yet we're keeping you on
the phone away from making money and
doing business right yes yes in the next
scene uh gabriel you'll play my son okay
who only speaks spanish there you go go
ahead let's do this
can you help my son out
sir
no habla espanol
he don't speak spanish
oh okay [ __ ] all right all right this
has got to be how are we going to do
this
okay can we do something where okay
you don't do upholstering or anything
like that i'm trying to think of a
really good i i do not no i do not
so if gabriel keeps speaking
engineering tesla pardon me
i'll put a v8 engine in your tesla
you're not what's your name john
yeah i'm john yeah don't please don't
joke around we're trying to do a prank
call here
it's not laughing matter this is my
podcast
that's my son
gabby that's gabrielle iglesias and
howie mandel and this is for my podcast
how the heck did you guys get my number
dear god oh caroline uh caroline who
produces the show caroline tell him how
you got his number um
you actually had very good ratings so i
called i called you the other day and i
spoke with you i think but i pretended
to be someone else
because she will she'll set up these
prank calls like weeks in advance
and they thought that when you answered
the phone you felt like somebody she
said to me this guy's gullible he'll
fall for anything
this will be talking to max yeah max oh
do you want us to talk to max then yeah
you just got max is here uh he should
have been here half an hour ago so max
is [ __ ] late max is getting
get it together max
he's getting fired is he getting fired
no actually you know what i i read the
clock wrong he'll be here in half an
hour
wait
i don't understand all right he works
that he works at one o'clock so okay so
can we start the prank
enough i'm trying to do a prank
john
john
yeah howie go for it okay
uh gabriel's going to be my son in this
one and it's my adopted son see yes that
means yes in spanish
[Laughter]
which means in english john that means
the car
is broken
oh you get it too much man [ __ ] you just
made my day
this is the the most lame prank call
i've ever been part of we asked for
permission
you aren't playing a lot that's the time
we're living in how you gotta you gotta
get consent for a prank call
i got consent he said we can do it but
now you got to get pissed john
you got to get i have to get pissed well
that's then makes the prank funny if
we're [ __ ] with you
howie here's the thing your own speaker
i got four customers sitting in my
office waiting to get serviced and each
one of them has a grin
from end to end on their face and how
the hell do i get pissed i can't get
pissed you can't are the customers there
they're all here they all go wow get out
now
this is the worst company i have ever
dealt with there's no customer service
whatsoever he won't even talk to my son
listen to what my son has to tell him
[Laughter]
that's gabriel iglesias and howie mandel
what's wrong with that yes
they're all on the podcast is it okay
ask the customers is is it okay for us
to [ __ ] with them this is a new age
where you have to ask people nice oh
yeah this is how i won last week
i think
you love
this is it anybody gonna
she loves us why are you there what's
wrong with your car
my mustang
oh she had to give us the brand my
mustache my mustache
i have a brand new mustang
yes
i'd have a mustang i didn't ask you what
kind of car i said what's wrong with
your car
oh okay well yeah uh breaks and uh it
wouldn't start so john breaks and it
wouldn't start well i love that oh it
doesn't start or go
starter stop start a stop sorry it
doesn't start or stop but it's a mustang
anyway what did what did john say the
problem is
okay yeah this is a great prank there we
go anyway are you guys enjoying the
prank
i think they're gone
i think they hung up oh then they must
have been really mad once you once you
hang up you're you're done yeah that's
it yeah that was a great that was good
that was your fault by the way you typed
in the wrong number who did you
you done i blew it yeah you blew okay so
this is a fail prank sometimes pranks
fail this was a good fail
was it good
um
you've been honest up until this point
no it was a fail it was a fail so we but
we failed together we did two bald guys
failed nice it is nice
[Music]